main story this morning i'm sorry but
i'm staying the message from the prime
minister who's standing firm amid calls
to quit after being fined for breaking
his own lockdown rules the question now
is will he face further fines for five
more events he's been linked to his
chancellor too receiving a fine let's
take a look back at the timeline of
events for the events linked to boris
johnson specifically the prime minister
has been fined for his birthday
celebration on the 19th of june 2020
where it's claimed that up to 30 people
attended a party with cake in the
cabinet room the previous month and on
the 20th of may about 100 staff from
number 10 were invited to a bring your
own booze event in the dining street
garden on the 13th of november mr
johnson gave a speech at the leaving do
for his director of communications on
the same day it's also alleged that
carrie johnson hosted a party
in the number 10 flat it's claimed there
was a christmas quiz at number 10 on the
15th of december the pm insists it was
virtual this event is not being
investigated by the police
and two days later on the 17th of
december it's believed mr johnson
attended another event for a number 10
official uh on the fourth i've received
a
fixed penalty notice from the
metropolitan police relating to an event
in downing street on the 19th of june
2020 and let me say immediately that
i've paid the fine and i once again
offer a full
apology at that time
it did not occur to me uh that this
might have been a breach of the rules
but of course the police have found
otherwise and i
fully respect the outcome
of their investigation
i understand the anger that many will
feel that i myself fell short when it
came to observing the very rules which
the government i lead had introduced to
protect the public
short straw this morning falls to
transport secretary grant chaps mr
schaps thank you so much for taking the
time to join us we know it's going to be
a challenging morning for you but we
appreciate you taking the time uh at
least 50 fixed penalty notices issued so
far potentially more to come it appears
that downing street has one of the
highest crime rates in the country this
morning the pm has presided over that
how can he possibly remain in office
good morning okay well look first of all
i um i know that the the prime minister
has apologized for this you just heard
him say he accepts responsibility and
he's reorganized number 10 but you know
i for one um as somebody who couldn't
see my own dad for four months during
this
period during lockdowns whilst he was in
hospital
and we didn't know that we'd see him
again
completely understand the upset and
anger that this causes because i feel it
myself
and
the one thing i know and i spoke to the
uh the prime minister uh is he is
completely mortified um by
this happening and we know now a lot
more about the day itself as well
because uh
we understand about the meetings that
were going on eight separate meetings
that day before the prime minister went
out and visited a school and came back
and uh and uh by surprise uh some of his
team had
uh
arranged to wish him happy birthday it
shouldn't have happened he's paid the 50
quid fine that's the right thing to to
do he's reorganized number 10 and i
think he's got a big job to do
uh particularly with um the cost of
living
inflation those pressures and of course
all of that coming about because of the
the war in ukraine and i think he's
shown terrific leadership with regard to
the west's response to that war
so far he's presided over 50 separate
rule breaks at downing street including
that of his wife
and his chancellor likely that more rule
breaks will be recognised by the police
to come another five events that he
reportedly attended how can he possibly
remain in office
well look
and everyone is is human people
sometimes make mistakes he wasn't there
for the 50 events that you're referring
to of course and many times it was
wasn't even in the in the building um
he's human and humans are and sometimes
they make mistakes okay and
and and that's what happened here has
been a very high profile job and quite
rightly uh the police have uh
investigated
independently come to their their view
he's apologized he's accepted
responsibility he's paid the 50 quid uh
fine um the question i suppose your
question goes to the heart of uh you
know
did he set out to do this was this
something that was done with with malice
with intent and the answer of course is
is is no it's something that happened uh
in error uh and uh
as i said i've spoken to him he's
incredibly embarrassed by the whole
thing he he he knows that it was stupid
and defensible um but
he didn't set out to break the law uh
and he's paid the fixed penalty notice
uh fine uh and has a very big job to to
do it
ignorance is no defense in law is it
that's right okay but you know as you
know so occasionally people bird on the
wrong side of the law during lockdown
and uh you know he has uh quite rightly
paid the price 50 quid in in this case
and and of course reputational uh damage
but um
the question who should be responsible
for the goings-on in dining street when
on at least
50 separate occasions the law was broken
even not the prime minister
well even when the prime minister wasn't
there he's already said he takes full
responsibility
and the law was broken and
and this was um as you can see this is
two years ago this particular incident
and um you know since then he's
completely reformed number ten being
very large changes as you know in and
personnel but look i i don't i i don't
think there's any is that i
personally
when i heard about these goings on was
very upset i didn't think i'd see my dad
again you know i think that a lot of
people in the country will have felt the
same way about it it absolutely
shouldn't happen it's
incredibly serious and quite rightly
that's been recognized and fines being
paid who's responsible mr shap who's
responsible for at least 50 rule breaks
law breaks at downing street
obviously individuals who who
are not the prime minister he doesn't
have overall responsibility
of course he does
okay so he's responsible for 50 times
the law being broken in downing street
and yet he still remains was his honor
many of those times he won't have been
there but nonetheless he says himself he
takes over responsibility and i think
that's absolutely the right thing for
him to do yeah it's the first time that
a prime minister has broken the law in
the history of the office more than 300
years since robert walpole uh took
office uh he's brought the role into
disrepute where's his honor
well as i as i've said i think he in
accepting and apologizing and paying the
fine and reforming number 10 and getting
on with the job including in ukraine uh
being uh one of perhaps the uh most uh
proactive we're talking about
if we may please mr we're not talking
about ukraine we're talking specifically
about partygate this morning let's stay
on topic you're talking about p
reforming dining street five people have
resigned 45 separate breaches so
allegra stratton's gone done rosenfeld's
gone martin reynolds have gone jack
dole's gone kate joseph's gone 45 other
breaches who's responsible for those you
say that he's reformed downing street
only five people have gone 50 breaches
that's clearly not true because there
are a number of other people who haven't
mentioned have gone in including dominic
cummings uh lee kane and many others are
you saying that dominick comics broke
the rules
i i look i'm not i'm not getting into
specifics of anybody well you just did
saying there's more than five but i'm
simply saying hey there's more than five
people who've gone the most important
thing is it's not just it's not just
about who's come and gone it's also
about the fact he's now set up an office
of the prime minister to specifically
look after the way that the uh the
operation of number 10 uh works and you
know i think it's worth understanding uh
that in number 10 the prime minister who
leads a particularly busy uh diary of
course goes from one meeting to the next
to the next that doesn't matter
it doesn't matter well let me doesn't
matter 57 no let me just put it to you
50 separate occasions so far
that had the law has been broken in
downing street the prime minister set
the law the prime minister broke the law
the prime minister misled parliament
where's his honor
no okay by the same logic anybody who
broke a lockdown law wouldn't be in
their job would they the point of this
is the prime minister
when we've made a mistake continually
lying when we've made a mistake blaming
others and not accepting responsibility
we know that people have done that in
the past is not a good look for a
politician for a public servant
especially the prime minister where's
his honor
so it's not a good look for anyone but
he has not done that what he's done is
accepted for responsibility you keep
asking the same question
i've answered it absolutely but i can't
do unless you let me get a word in uh i
want to absolutely answer it the simple
answer is he takes full responsibility
for all those breaches whether he was
there or in the vast vast majority
exactly
not there and so on 50 separate
occasions the law was broken
and there will be more to come
we are told or certainly led to believe
by the police including five separate
events that the prime minister attended
this is just one event that he's been
fined for that his wife and his
chancellor were at five other events as
well i could go through them if you want
i'm sure you're aware of them if he
receives more signs
if he receives more fines and he then
subsequently quite obviously misled
parliament both on the 1st of december
and the 8th of december when he was at
the dispatch box he should go where is
his honor
i look i i appreciate that what you're
doing is listing everything that you can
that you've got to list there but i
would prefer that we leave this to the
police i think they're the right people
to uh come to conclusions on that and
they've decided he broke the law what
they have to say they've decided and
he's apologized and he's accepted
responsibility and he's reformed number
10 and he's getting on with um doing the
job and as i say i completely get what
you're saying okay because i've been in
the position myself of not being able to
see uh my own family uh under these
circumstances i find it i'm very annoyed
by it i find it you know angers me
greatly i've spoken to the prime
minister he's mortified but just to be
absolutely clear i think motive is very
important in the situation like this
he didn't go out uh to with mattis to go
and uh break the law he was very very he
had a blatant disregard he made the laws
and he had a blatant disregard for them
20th of may bring your own booze party
19th of june he's already been fined for
13th of november party after dominic
cummings and lee kane quit 15th of
december christmas quiz attended by the
pm where there was booze and tinsel 17th
of december two uh events there 14th of
january leaving drinks the pm allegedly
attended you know that's not just all he
made a mistake that's six separate
occasions the law that he made he was
the policy maker he broke the law he
then went to parliament and said don't
know what you're talking about it must
have been them it's not me he was lying
he was hiding behind other people they
fell on their sword and he continues to
say that he's going to stay in office
where is his honor
you just listed a whole bunch of events
uh in which the police have not in fact
ruled uh as yet not yet didn't knowingly
he didn't so if they rule against him
with those other five events will he go
then
okay
he didn't knowingly um break the law
didn't do it deliberately he didn't come
to parliament and and uh having
knowingly done this he he thought in
fact uh the the same people who uh
wished him happy birthday who'd already
been meeting with uh earlier that day uh
was not breaking the law if the police
take a different view he absolutely
accepts that and has paid the fine i see
what you're doing which is to sort of
list everything else that you've read in
the in the newspapers or reported i
think it's fair to allow the police to
take a look at that rather than jump to
all of those okay so let's follow that
through then should we what will it take
for the pm to leave office will it be
more fines will that be the stage where
he has to accept that he's not an
honorable man
i don't agree okay we live in a
democracy and people have every right to
vote to
decide what happens with their
representatives uh i think a lot of
people take the view that
went wrong here
i i think helpful if i can just get one
answer out i think a lot of people take
the view that although this clearly uh
went wrong it's very serious i don't uh
i don't seek to minimize it in any way
shape or form not least because i feel
pretty aggrieved about uh things like
myself given not being able to see my
own family
most people look at this understand that
we're talking about an event nearly two
years ago that he's apologized his
deceptive responsibility his reform
number ten and although you don't want
to talk about this either that he's
getting on and helping to lead the
western's response west's response
because that's not the topic of
discussion this morning if you'll
forgive me i'm leading the interview mr
shaps and let me say you brought up the
fact that it was a democracy
75
of the public if i may if i may i wanted
to respond to your suggestion that it's
a democracy 75 of the public
75
of the public feel that he continually
and deliberately lied how can he
remain in office as an honorable man i'm
guessing from what you're saying you
think he is an honorable man
i do and
the last part of the point that i was
trying to answer is relevant here even
though you keep telling me it's not
people judge somebody in the round they
judge how they do their job overall i'm
not saying that the prime minister uh
isn't a flawed individual we're all
flawed different ways we all uh the
question is did somebody set out to do
these things with malus and actually
overall is he doing a good job as prime
minister which is why i do think it's
relevant how he performs the rest of his
job the rest of his uh task uh and uh
and and he made a mistake it was
embarrassing and and stupid the prime
minister's mortified
about it but i think there's a big job
for him to get on and and do uh on
behalf of the british people on behalf
of the uh the world fighting this this
this cruel uh walk and and that is why i
judge him in the round and you know okay
you say you judge him in the round but
absolutely and i must let you go in a
second because we're running out of time
you say he judged him in the round he's
already been sacked twice for lying um
he uh slurred um hillsborough fans uh
suggesting that they were partially
drunken fans were partially responsible
for what happened in 1989. he was uh
failing to be completely transparent
about the downing street flat charging
840 pounds a roll for wallpaper when
people can't put food in their kids
bellies and and then he allegedly uh
promised a business interest for
jennifer our curie who was his alleged
lover let's judge him in the round
he
helped to make sure this country
received vaccines before any other
country in the world got the roll out
and the booster done got us out of
lockdown before anyone else gave us the
fastest growing economy in the g7 last
year and as well leading the world's
response uh to uh president putin
according to president zielenski i take
somebody in the round okay and i think
that this prime minister has much more
to give and that is why despite the fact
that i think what happened was wrong uh
he has apologized his accepted
responsibility he's paid his 50 quid
fine
and he's getting on
with his very important job running the
country